un présent sur les propos d' emmanuel
macron tenus dans le journal le parisien
on en parlait au début de ce journal on
va aller dans le détail en compagnie
d'hélène phrase pour la revue de presse
bonjour hélène jourda la une des
journaux donc ce matin il y a cet
entretien des manuels macron avec les
lecteurs du journal le parisien une
interview sur fond de vague omicron et
de campagne présidentielle non
démocratie le pire ennemi c'est le
mensonge et la bêtise les non vaccinés
j'ai très envie de les emmerder et donc
on va continuer de le faire jusqu'au
bout voilà pour la phrase choc tirer de
ce très longue entretien qui aborde
aussi la présidence française de l'union
européenne et bien sûr la présidentielle
sur ce sujet le président se défend
d'entretenir un faux suspense j'ai envie
déclare emmanuel macron qui promet de
clarifier sa position dès que les
conditions sanitaires le permettront je
le cite d'où le dessin de rançon ou de
français demande au président s'il va se
représenter lisez sur mes lèvres propose
emmanuel marc roux derrière son masque
je sais ce sera plus facile quand la
pandémie sera terminée
les propos du président sur les non
vaccinés ne contribue pas à apaiser la
polémique à 7 le féminisme notamment à
l'assemblée actuellement le salaire en
plein débat sur le pass vaccinale le
figaro cite notamment la réaction du
président du patron des républicains
christian jacob qui dit refuser je le
cite de cautionner un texte visant à
emmerder les français résultat des
courses nouvelle suspension de séance
cette nuit aux alentours de deux heures
du matin au palais bourbon les débats
doivent reprendre dans la journée elle a
eu également de la presse dans le monde
le premier anniversaire demain de
l'assaut contre le capitole aux états
unis attaque qui avait fait cinq morts
et des dizaines de blessés un an après
la libération va dans la voix la
démocratie américaine en péril mener
c'est par les coups de boutoir d'une
partie de la droite américaine toujours
galvanisé par le mythe de l'élection
volée loin d'être le chant du cygne d'un
président antidémocratique donald trump
l'attaquent du capitole était au
contraire un coup d'essai
le journal dont le produit diagnostic un
très sombre s'appuie sur plusieurs
éléments le noyautage de l'armée par des
forces anti-démocratiques le financement
massif de milices d'extrême droite
l'instauration de lois permettant de
contourner le vote dans des états clés
et bien sûr l'avalanche le flot
incessant de fake news sur la façon dont
joe biden aurait volé l'élection
présidentielle libé site d'amiens le
philosophe français alexis de
tocqueville une idée fausse mais claires
et précises aura toujours plus de
puissance qu'une idée vrai mais complexe
mais d'après le new york times de la
halle tram n'est pas le seul responsable
de cet assaut du capital et le journal
explique que si la tête du 6 janvier est
bien le fruit de la rhétorique
incendiaire d'une partie des
conservateurs et de l'influencé des
réseaux sociaux elle est aussi le
résultat d'un problème structurel lié au
fonctionnement même des institutions
américaines selon lui ces institutions
ont elles aussi elles aussi contribué à
produire cette explosion de violence en
créant un sentiment de droit au pouvoir
au sein de la minorité conservatrice les
avantages structurels dont jouissent les
conservateurs dans notre système
électoral sont bien connus par deux fois
déjà depuis le début de ce siècle le
parti républicain a remporté le collège
électoral et donc la présidence tout en
ayant perdu le vote populaire analyse le
journal qui souhaite donc logiquement
une fune révision une évolution de la
constitution américaine un changement
difficile à envisager normal puisqu'il
nécessite un soutien bibi partisans
c'est à dire à la fois des démocrates et
des républicains notamment la présence
de cette polémique dont on entend parler
dans le journal polémique provoquée par
cette dérogation accordée au tennisman
novak djokovic pour pouvoir disputer
l'open d'australie alors qu'il n'est a
priori pas vacciner cette dérogation
vous l'avez dit dont on ignore le motif
pour des raisons de secret médical
provoque la colère du courrier ou mail
i-mode big joe king c'est une
plaisanterie titre ce matin le quotidien
australien avec un jeu de mots sur le
patronyme du joueur serbe novak djokovic
dernière est connue pour être un adepte
des médecines douces dont il a souvent
vanté
merritt sur son compte instagram
notamment où il a donné la parole entre
autres à des illuminés prêchant des
théories sur les bonnes ondes ou encore
la purification de l'eau par la pensée
bah voyons on se quitte pas là dessus
elle avant de dire admet damien je vous
propose d'acheter un silo times qui fait
état d'une initiative ma foi assez
original l'initiative de mme ahmed malik
il a 22 ans il a 29 ans par dont il a
choisi pour se trouver une épouse n'ont
pas de partir à la pêche sur les sites
de rencontre mais de s'afficher on le
voit sur des panneaux publicitaires
géants dans la ville de birmingham au
royaume uni sauvez moi d'un mariage
arrangé indique son annonce même si
mamad mali que damien a tenu à préciser
qu'il n'est pas contre le principe je
pense que les mariages arrangés août une
place et une tradition dans de
nombreuses cultures islamiques je le
cite en fait de nombreuses études
montrent que les mariages arrangés
présente de nombreux avantages je veux
juste essayer de trouver quelqu'un par
moi même d'abord avis aux intéressés
sachez que la partenaire idéale
recherchée est une jeune femme musulmane
dans l'aveyron dans la vingtaine qui
s'efforcent je cite toujours de trouver
la fois le message est passé merci
beaucoup et elle en a vu là à l'adresse
de son site internet sur sur son affiche
transition toute trouvée vers le grand
salon des lots